hey guys we are now in our new year and
we believe we are planning to align your
career life and health to set cause to
success this video is dedicated to
helping you with the same we bring you
some simple suggestions and a list of
top 10 resolutions you should focus on
you are watching simply learn and if
these are the type of videos you would
like to watch then click that subscribe
button and hit the Bell so that you
won't miss out on any of the future
videos so the top 10 resolution is to
plant a tree or a sapling to protect and
preserve the planet we all know that the
world is switching to The Greener forms
of energy and trying to save the planet
one step at a time as a part of the
ecosystem we are responsible to save our
planet and what's a better resolution
than giving a better planet to your
future Generations
next we have finances as the ninth
resolution Achieve Financial
sustainability saving investing and
spending judicially will help you
everyone out there has the desire to
lead a successful life to do so you need
to plan your budget by understanding the
difference between needs and liabilities
seek expert advice on investments and
try to save whenever and wherever
possible this earns you alternate
incomes and helps you find Financial
Freedom the next resolution is plan to
work out at least four days a week being
stuck in the nine to five without
focusing on your physical health might
impact you in many ways a strong
resolution that motivates you to wake up
early and work out and keep your body
fit and your organs healthy eating fewer
calories maintaining a healthy diet
playing more and getting six to eight
hours of sleep according to your body
needs can help you next is focusing on
your mental health as yourself 7th
resolution start a meditation practice
the everyday grind of your routine can
exhaust your brain you need to assist
your brain to enhance the optimum
performance of your brain cells the
brain is incredibly resilient and has
the ability to repair itself through the
process of neuroplasticity
you can further amplify the results by
meditating following a healthy diet and
exercising in a pleasant environment the
sixth one on the list is to learn
something new read books this might
sound a little out of trend but I
believe some people love reading books
reading improves your vocabulary memory
power and helps you stay focused reading
is considered a therapy to reduce stress
and helps people develop empathy to
build a better relationship with people
around them
a recent survey conducted by popular
University States reading can reduce
stress levels by up to 68 percent having
said that our fifth resolution can be to
master a new skill
a professional a student and every
knowledgeable person know learning is
Evergreen learning a new skill always
helps you you might add social skills
presentation skills cooking driving and
many more if you are a 90 professional
looking to get trained and certified
with new it skills simply learn would be
your One-Stop solution offering you a
wide range of digital skills to master
and get certified with that we can
proceed to our fourth resolution which
is to stop procrastinating
procrastination is the biggest enemy of
progress try to stop procrastinating if
something is wrong or you did not
achieve your goals as per your plan I
believe procrastination was the biggest
culprit among all other reasons stopping
there and worrying about what happened
will not help instead rise up and give
it another try now we are at the last
three resolutions the third one is to
enjoy little things in life set smaller
and achievable goals I admit everyone
has bigger dreams but it's a fact that
room was not built in a day so I suggest
you to try and follow the assembly type
approach to your dream look at the
smaller picture understand what it takes
to achieve the dream back the easier
wins and use a longer Runway to fly high
the second one is to increase your
emotional intelligence control your
emotions situations may not be always
the same and there are many chances
where things might get out of control
and loss might not be contained it's the
time when you understand the situation
and act accordingly believe that you can
find a solution in one way or the other
being calm and finding the most feasible
solution is the only way to contain the
problem the last and the most important
resolution is to create positive
attitude believe that it's okay and do
not go too hard on yourself as you might
already be doing much better create a
positive attitude and open up your mind
to New Opportunities it makes it easier
for you to bring peace to your life so
these were the top 10 New Year
resolutions by simply Dawn hope you
enjoyed watching it we wish you all the
best for your New Year stay safe keep
learning and get ahead you're watching
simply learn and stay tuned for more